[Music]
i demand to speak to the man in charge
i am ostawatami john brown
i am in charge mr brown i'm lieutenant
colonel robert e lee of the united
states army
i'm here on orders by president james
buchanan to demand
that you and your outlaws surrender this
fort
i'm willing to offer leniency in
exchange for a peaceful surrender
i hate to disappoint you colonel but
you're not likely to get a peaceful
anything from us
not while that abomination called
slavery
is still the law of this land
not when negro blood flows in our rivers
and irrigates our crops
not till every last man woman and child
is freed from their chains will we ever
surrender
you are evidently a man of passion mr
brown
i can respect that but i'm not here to
make moral judgments
i'm here to enforce the law
and i am here to enforce a higher law
extolled you might recall in the
declaration of independence
that all men are created equal
you gotta remind you mr brown that the
man that penned those words was a slave
owner
are you accusing thomas jefferson
one of our founding fathers
of being a hypocrite well i read it
he didn't think colored people were men
who is it decides who is a man or not
colonel
almighty god or thomas jefferson
i'll go with god so i'm to take it
you'll not go down without a fight
take it as you will sir
so be it
send them in yes sir
[Music]
company forward mod
[Music]
ready
all right
pretty good
oh
oh
[Music]
what
[Music]
oh
shoulders in it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the catacombs
[Music]
[Music]
we've chosen a scene that we thought it
brings the whole movie together
it's it's a historical scene it's pretty
close to historically accurate that
scene
and we thought this is a good scene for
us to
look at analyze and talk about and we
all have something to say about it
so i'm gonna let reggie
chime in and say hi hi um
i really like this scene for a couple of
reasons um
it was obviously uh it combines
so much so much of what was important
about the film which is that
you have a conceptual battle between
robert e lee
who at this point is still on the union
side he is
you know the the civil war has not
broken out the confederate
uh side has not emerged so he's fighting
on behalf of the u.s government
against the great john brown who is an
abolitionist who is taking this very
bold stance
on the uh he's trying to create
disruptive incident that in his mind
will inspire a movement
uh a massive revolt amongst the
plantations
and will lead to the
collapse of slavery so
uh you know they have a first a battle
of minds
and of wills over these ideas and then
uh it turns into you know let's get into
some gangster stuff
so and
um a wonderful performance uh
by dale who um
is again his his initial mission was
very simple i want to
save my family from slavery uh and then
you know via john brown well
perhaps if i join these men i can end
slavery not just for my family
but for everyone and he puts his trust
into john brown who is of course
incredibly well intended
but he has had a suspicion for a while
that this is going to turn into a death
trap so here he is
he knew he was right he didn't follow
his actions
and now he's got to fight for his own
life in the life of the men around him
who are all good men uh who are about to
die for a very noble cause
yeah i agree i agree reggie and it's
funny to me
there are a lot of things going on in
that scene and i can let you guys talk
more about the choreography and you know
the amazing wardrobe and
the props and just those things that
really put you back in that era
but for me i just want to talk a little
bit about the psychological aspect of
that scene for me and
what was going on in my head in that
scene and this goes back to a lot of
conversations that
mark and i and reggie and cami all had
which was that
we should not be we should be very
careful about making
shields a superhuman hero you know
and how we wanted this film to define
what courage is
you know what i'm saying and you know
courage is not the absence of fear like
courage is
feeling the weight of fear in the moment
right the gravity of the situation but
doing what is true
and doing what is right anyway and so i
was always
in my mind i was like just always
remember the stakes the stakes the
stakes
and it becomes very dire when you start
seeing your fellow brothers
you know hit dirt you know what i'm
saying they're going down one by one you
know and
in very quick secession which i loved
editorially how that was
done and it felt that way when we filmed
filmed it that
you know the good guys start going down
one by one very quickly and so
you kind of have john and shields
looking around and you're still trying
to
keep the morale high but the the team
the fellowship is falling apart if i can
borrow from tolkien for a second
so it was it's it's those moments you
know those moments of absolute fear but
the the greats you know whether it's the
harriet tubmans or the john brown
john browns of the shields green they're
the ones who in that moment
showed that they they were somewhat
super human because
even in the with the fear and the eyes
and the shaking and the
trembling they're able to still do what
is right no matter what that's why we
celebrate them at the end of the day
because
we all aren't capable of that you know
most people would cower in those
situations but that's why they deserve
to be remembered so
the weight of it was always on my mind
for me it was very important that this
scene looks like a real battlefield i've
seen so many movies where people are
just
in battlefields they're just running
randomly at each other shooting killing
each other
and then they edit it together but i
wanted to see to have a strategy i would
say okay if this was a
real battle i've been i've done military
service and i think okay if this was a
real battle how would they do it and we
did some research
and for example the scene i want to
point out is if the details a lot of
people have picked up and commented on
is with the channel being fired uh
at the thing and then robert e lee goes
and picks a sharpshooter and
sees what what what hold the camera the
challenge shots are coming from on
points so they tell them to shoot at
that's like not random events and i
think we that that that's the kind of
stuff that i was trying to do and
at the same time i didn't want at dyer
said we didn't want it to be over the
top we didn't want to look like some
kind of a you know
over-the-top action film it tracks yeah
ultimately market tracks that's the
thing yeah when you're watching it you
don't get lost in the chaos
tracking character and tracking story
yeah you see the military tactics and
all that stuff
and they want to say we you know in
terms of crew we got really lucky we had
this guy
uh first lady his name was jd
after a couple weeks i started calling
jedi
and that became like his nickname and he
was so but he was literally like a
military commander he was
rehearsing these soul extras and making
i mean
it was amazing i don't think without him
we could have had this kind of a
coordination
and everything yeah and then the other
thing if you guys notice
um there's a scratch mark on john
brown's
nose yeah and this is for example
example
thing that i like to talk about if
somebody is making movies that that was
not planned what happened
during the actual raid that the events
john brown actually accidentally got hit
by john brown i mean
that hit on the nose there's no started
bleeding
being a great actor and a professional
he said i don't and you know he's not a
young
man he's doing his own stunts he was
doing his own stunts and said let's keep
going
so and we couldn't we didn't want to put
the band-aid on his so he said okay
let's just make it part of the uh part
of scene and then there's another scene
which is not here where we actually
see in the movie his nose getting hit so
these are the kind of stuff that i think
we try to use to make the movie
authentic but also roll with the punches
we have a problem with it
we have a problem or a limitation you
try to take advantage of it
and make it part of the scene as opposed
to
trying to fight it or eliminate it yeah
no i was i was just gonna talk about the
cinematography and maybe you could talk
about that
too reggie because this sequence i can't
tell you how many times
thunder started and rain started we'd
have to run away for a second
come back shoot like five minutes the
rain will come back again
go away come back so the fact that it
looks
like it's always sunny in continuity
that's just
blows me away because in my mind i'm
like this is going to be a hot mess when
they cut this thing together when we're
filming it
but to see all the work that went post
on that is is truly incredible but
yeah so i'm sorry reggie let me say
because he brought up the thunder and
problems
what happened right in the middle of
scene outside fort jackson in the middle
like about three o'clock in the
afternoon
they came to me and whispered to a
mirror to my in my ears that mark we've
discovered the dead body
on the back of the set i said okay first
starting to say oh my god that's because
we had such a hot
hot day so and we've actually had people
you know pass out from heat to say oh my
god somebody died what the hell are we
going to do
you thought it was interesting no no no
no it's it's a skeleton they found
that been there for 20 30 years that
during this shoot we actually had
discovered it
so we made the decision right there and
then i think with kami and reggie were
there we decided
not to tell anyone until the shoot was
over now if there was a fresh body we
would have had to tell them
okay if someone's been dead for 30 days
they can wait another three hours so
so go ahead reggie i'm sorry i had to
share that since he brought up
thunder yeah yeah
thanks for the uh yeah okay uh this is
skeleton story
it's like the haunted movie
i got nothing but actually my favorite
part of the scene
well there's a couple of these one is uh
um you know you know
you and james cromwell having you know
these incredible moments
where you know his men are dying around
him including his own children
right uh and you know
and john brown realizes like they're not
going to be able to hold the fort right
so they fall back
they're facing the door um the the the
the big doors of the vault
of the fault fort for the final showdown
he looks at you and he's lost so many of
his children
and he knows that you're here for your
son
yeah and he waves you away like
get out of here at least if you know you
should not die in this like that's my
choice
and and and then john leads the rest of
his men to the catacombs
so hopefully they can uh avoid getting
shot
and a few brave man stand there to hold
the line
and you hear the battle ram on the other
side
and you know look if you're on the other
side with your four
rifles and you know there's an army on
the other side that's a
scary sound and then
the the hammering stops and they're like
did they give up
did they walk away what's happening and
then boom the final thing
the battle ram knocks the gates open
mayhem yeah and those those extras were
great those background
guys like they were in it and i'm so
happy they got like nice little
close-ups to show the different ranges
of emotions between
you know some people are super
courageous and some people are a little
bit
extremely afraid and so i love that they
got those nice little close-ups really
see
you know that they're not just
background each each of these men have a
whole life
to themselves and a whole world that
they're sacrificing for a moment like
that you know it justifies that close up
you're exactly right and you know it's
it's such a cliche but it's really true
no small part i mean there's no small
party small actors
and you know uh you know those actors
you know that we got uh you know they're
in town
they were ready for the moment and they
were in it
you felt them you felt their fear you
felt their courage
uh you felt their hesitation they
lowered their arms a little bit like oh
maybe
oh this is it oh good uh so yeah it was
it's great that uh you know if they did
not
nail it the way they did the scene
wouldn't work you know
just as important as yours and reggie to
confirm that a lot of this stuff
was uh you know improvised on this on
the set with extras
with but also with actors uh anyway this
scene was
is a example of all this stuff coming
together
with all of our team and then dye of
course by the time we got to this scene
he was really found his legs and he was
just firing all cylinders no
it was look it was a great experience
and
your sincere passion and love for this
subject
uh uh that would you know you know when
you talked about it
you know you would get teary-eyed which
would make me all choked up
and you know that passion you know got
everyone
uh invested and involved and i think
that passion shows on screen
so uh kudos to you kudos to
daio kudos to everyone who did whatever
it take to make this happen and make
something beautiful
so thank you thank you thanks everyone
take care